the youtubers is Charlie huge news
Marvel just confirmed they're doing an
Inhumans TV show in fall of 2017 like
this time next year so I'm gonna explain
what the hell's going on but this is
gonna be awesome this is so crazy that
Marvel would do a list characters on TV
in this way but you can kind of see what
they're doing this is like the
in-between option for doing a character
in the movies and doing a character on
TV is like they started out with this
like big blockbuster two-hour pilot that
they drop in an IMAX theater and then
they do the rest of the series on TV
like a normal TV show so if you don't
know what's going on Inhumans was
originally going to be like a phase four
movie tail end phase three like they
were gonna work him in right after the
first infinity war movie
but then supposedly there was a lot of
infighting behind the scenes Kevin Feige
wasn't really interested in doing
Inhumans he was the idea of Isaac
Perlmutter the guy who owns Marvel
remember I did a big video about how he
almost quashed the spider-man deal with
Sony in how he's generally thought of is
not the nicest person in the world he's
like the toy guy at marble so supposedly
he really wanted the Inhumans because
you could turn that into a big franchise
it could be like Marvel's version of
x-men just because of the way their
powers work but it seems like what
they're doing now is they're just gonna
try and turn it into Marvel's Network
Game of Thrones because you have the
Iron Throne in Westeros
now you have the throne of at to land in
the Marvel Universe so whatever happened
behind the scenes they made the decision
to turn it into a TV show it's gonna be
on ABC it will not be a spin-off of
agents of shield so it's not gonna rely
on any of the Canon that they set up in
the first couple of seasons so I think
that's to their benefit so they're gonna
be able to do all of the comic-book
Inhumans royal family stuff the series
is supposed to follow the origins of
Black Bolt which means they'll do the
royal family they'll do at land all the
stuff that you wanted them to do on
agents of shield in the movies they're
going to be doing that but it'll be on
this Inhumans TV show they did say that
the IMAX pilot is gonna drop in
September they didn't say exactly when
but that'll be September and then the
rest of the series will premiere next
fall so like literally
next year we're gonna have an Inhumans
TV show around this time so if you've
been disappointed that agents of shield
has thus far not done a lot of movie
stuff like this everything's connected
but we haven't really seen any of the
Avengers do any big stuff on the show
but you know Ghost Rider is like the
real exception to that this season but
it seems like next year that's all gonna
change because they'll have the Inhumans
TV show they can crossover with agents
of shield anytime they want so the thing
about that though like I say they could
cross over
they haven't explained specifically what
time period this is gonna take place
during if it's gonna be contemporary or
if it's gonna be set in the past
so just to be determined on that like
they're a couple details they have not
revealed yet but let me know what you
guys think of that Royal Family's
storyline on TV I think it's gonna be a
lot of fun it has a lot of potential but
obviously we need to see a trailer we
need to see some footage to see what
it's actually going to look like but it
sounds like what they'll do is be you
know because they're gonna try and drop
the pilot episode in September in IMAX
theaters they'll spend most of next year
at the conventions hyping it up the same
way they hype up the Netflix series if
you want to read a good Inhumans comic
book story there are a couple out there
but realm of kings was a lot of fun
Marvel Knights Inhumans was really good
and then there was this story line
called Inhumans versus the Kree in 2000
that was pretty good too so either way
like you can pick up any hidden humans
comic you want but those are just a
couple of suggestions so of course when
it gets here I'll do videos for it
agents of shield is in its fourth season
I definitely think it's gonna get a
season five pick up but I think the
ghostwriter is driving a lot of their
ratings so I think what they're doing is
is they're just kind of planning for the
future of Marvel on ABC television like
they're not getting ready to cancel
agents of shield or anything like that
but I think that they're just planning
for it to go off the air in the near
future so that they have something else
waiting in the wings so it's kind of the
thing where they're like slowly trying
to evolve the way they use these
characters on TV so like agents of
shield started out you know relatively
real world there wasn't a lot of
superhero stuff happening then they did
their own version of Inhumans now
they're doing Ghost Rider so they're
just slowly doing bigger and bigger
stuff and then you have the Netflix
stuff that's going on so I think this
Inhumans show like they're Marvel
version of Game of Thrones is like
the answer to that like you thought what
we're doing before was cool this is
gonna be so much bigger so for those of
you asking about CG and stuff like that
they've been getting better and better
with the way they use CG in a really
good example of that is actually the
flash TV show they've started to use
more and more CG villains which used to
be super expensive but now it's starting
to get a little more affordable so you
can just do cooler stuff so if you have
absolutely no idea who the Inhumans are
there's actually like a quick trailer
here for inhumanity which was like a
special event in the comics that does a
pretty good job of explaining the
broad-strokes but they do kind of feel
like an x-men style team they were
created by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby way
back in the day about two years after
they created the x-men
so they debuted in like a Fantastic Four
title so they were like a Fantastic Four
crossover initially but here's the
footage they have hidden in our midst
for centuries
a strange race of genetically enhanced
beings known as the Inhumans the result
of an ancient experiment forged on the
plains of prehistory they have evolved
in seclusion until now
a bomb ignites spreading the catalytic
energies of the Terrigen mists the fall
of a kingdom gives rise to an army as
across the globe countless thousands are
revealed as Inhumans
now they are among us their powers are
raw and untested and as the pandemic
continues to spread the heroes of Earth
must face the rise of the original
superhuman race witness the Marvel
Universe flourish into inhumanity so
that event in the comics came at the end
of infinity and it was meant to
basically like spread out this big new
Inhumans storyline so that's probably
not gonna happen on the TV show they're
probably gonna do it some other way they
use that is the fish oil on agents of
shield the TV show it was kind of their
version of the Terrigen bomb but as we
learn more about the series I'll do more
videos they'll probably start dropping
more teasers early next year because if
they're gonna get that pilot out by
September that means they have to start
working on it real soon so we'll
probably find out who's playing the
Royal Family characters relatively
quickly but if you're bummed out this
isn't gonna be a movie do not be sad now
they have up to 22 hours to develop
these characters instead of just two
hours
the problem with movies is that you just
don't have time for character moments
like it's just a big action set piece so
in some cases like especially when you
have a big group of characters TV shows
can be better than the movies but be
sure to subscribe to get everything
what's gonna happen tonight is I'll post
my flash episode after that airs there's
a whole bunch of other stuff that I'm
gonna try and get to this week so the
other rumor that I'll leave you with is
that they're also gonna be dropping some
Justice League footage pretty soon they
didn't say officially when but I'll talk
more about that when I post my flash
video while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here for a really
cool spider-man Home Coming interview
video and you can click here to learn
all about Young Justice season 3 thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you